I was told that MSG was basically like
equated to like a hard narcotic and this
was third grade so it was really
shocking theme failure gasps it's not
right I think MSG stands for monosodium
glutamate MSG 'he's always had like a
really like negative connotation
everyone is always saying ms she's bad
try to avoid it it's not good for you I
[Music]
feel like it's not not safe I'm still
alive and everything so I'm scared
support I'm gonna be at it as cancel for
saying truth it's not ah ah we live I'm
gonna just guess on this false yeah wait
no I'm legal
[Music]
high-five
I heard that that's true that it brings
like a richer flavor I'm not sure if
it's exactly the same mommy flavor like
same umbrella world I'm going to say she
won on them I'm gonna say true I'm going
with true I'm gonna say I'll follow your
lead yeah yeah well done well done
we got popcorn it's popped popcorn it's
a little salty which I like light and
fluffy chill I'm gonna go pulse true
prize a little bit MSG oh no I dropped
it
I love ranch dressing I'm gonna say
there's no MSG in it I'm sure there's a
mystery in this because it's too good to
be true
yeah true it was just great to kind of
reconfirm that like it's not bad for you
I didn't know that MSG was in so many
different kinds of foods MSG's five it's
great